earlier on this summer we were thinking
be cool to make like a whole
feature-length movie that took most of
the year and ICS we had all this cool
equipment that we could do with the blue
screen and the special effects programs
like Adobe After Effects and I was on
the internet surfing we had gotten a 3d
program called cinema 4d XL and it had
this one site where at all these
different stars models and I'm like oh
cool
you know we can make a movie with this
stuff and we just start with some realms
that Joe had mentioned here had
mentioned you know using the blue screen
making a cockpit scene almost like a
little air battle and I know we thought
that'd be cool mmm didn't take much time
so it wouldn't impede on any other big
projects coming up so I took about a
week and we worked on this we decided
that we can make it you know probably
make into more of a big production movie
like we were talking about earlier on
the fall and even though it wasn't
useful and it was still working towards
our grants grad standard that mr. digger
and said we need it and nobody
complained and so I went to the newest
program like this documentary we're
doing now so it turned out pretty good
and now I do have a big like
feature-length movie going on and it
should be completed by March the idea
first originated when Nico came to me a
while ago and said you know for a video
requirement for ICS why don't we just do
a Star Wars cockpit scene since me and
him are you know big fans of the series
and I said sure while we were filming
you know the idea came up why don't we
just do a full-length feature film and I
guess one idea just led to the next in
we're doing the movie in programs like
Adobe After Effects where we can put in
stuff like lasers for a laser fight and
we use the 3d program to make little
snow explosions or when the lasers hit
the ground the blue screen it's a little
tough to take out it's time-consuming
but it's like little by little we finish
up the scenes with it
stuff to get time off of school to go
out and film on location like on the
hill for skiing or walking around while
we're talking or landing or speeder bike
scenes that we'll be doing later on I
think for having absolutely no budget
and you know this being our first movie
I think we're doing a pretty good job
the special effects I mean they don't
have that real but I think they're
pretty good I mean we try to do the
movie as professionally as we can like
when you have an excellent sequence in
pretty much any movie they drought
storyboards and that's what we've been
doing we try to give this a very
professional approach to it and we just
you know angle it the best we can I
think it's gonna be a nice finished
project we used semi-professional
equipment so we're able to make somewhat
professional special effects they look
extremely real but we're not a
big-budget movie also like to make the
lasers in Photoshop or in Adobe After
Effects will draw the laser in Photoshop
and then move it into After Effects
where we can animate the laser on top of
another video clip like one of us firing
a laser gun or somebody
and I can put another clip with the snow
explosion that I mentioned earlier on
top of that the leaves are either hits
bias or but it's on us we can do
something else also with After Effects I
think you know Vince he's enjoying it
yeah I mean he may have I was a little
stupid at first and I think he still
does I think but I think we're having a
really fun time filming it I think we'll
be happy to see how it comes out
you